[Music]
[Applause]
reggie miller the hall of famer joining
us on the program reggie of course
trying to keep it a secret from his son
who's a die-hard steph curry fan that
reggie was like oh look who reg has he's
got
did you know your dad said the boston
celtics were going to win the nba
championship instead of your golden
state warriors yes you did know that you
finally told him reg
i had to tell him i had to break the
news to him and he looked at me crazy
so and when they won last night go ahead
and finish
i was very happy
and what did you say to me i told you i
told you the warriors would win
see you shouldn't have to make your bed
or clean your room for a week because
uncle danny said you can't you don't
have to clean your room
i don't even know if you have to eat
vegetables or go to school you know i
think that that's only fair you know
what why don't you take your dad's car
out for a ride too i think you should be
able to do that as well
what do you think
you want to take the car out for a ride
i don't know
[Music]
well congratulations on uh golden state
winning the championship there reg when
did you know you were in trouble in this
series with your boston celtics
i felt i was in trouble
after game five for them to get that
huge victory at home when steph
struggled
and other guys like andrew wiggins which
a lot of people i i think uh coach van
gundy and mark were kind of talking
about this on the telecast last night
but what wiggins did throughout this
series and his defense on jason tatum
and look a world beater
coming into this final series against
katie and against giannis and against
uncle jimmy butler tatum was fantastic
and he was a non-factor in this series
and a lot of that has to do with the
individual defense of andrew wiggins
yeah i i think that was underrated i
think we looked at him offensively and
rebounding and we didn't factor in the
defense there i just thought and we've
talked about this before we were trying
to push jason's uh jason tatum into
stardom like he he was going to go into
that elite fraternity i just didn't
think that he was there yet doesn't mean
he doesn't get there
but it just felt like he was regressing
in the finals how much does that do to
him and due to golden state i think it's
a combination of both
but i'll disagree with you a little bit
because i think he's in that
conversation i think his body of work
he has proven that over time what he did
against kd in four games was phenomenal
and especially what he did against
giannis
a former finals mvp and a world champion
you can't discredit that or discount
that i just think you know a lot of
people and i think you mentioned this
earlier they don't give the golden state
warriors enough credit defensively
because when we think of golden state we
think of threes
and
you know those guys and their antics we
forget
how solid
mark jackson originally and now steve
kerr with the warriors what they've done
defensively during this championship run
it's just been phenomenal and before you
go on i gotta give him a hug he's headed
to science camp give me a hug
i know don't rub it in okay i love you
say bye mr patrick
see you buddy
yeah
he knows more basketball than his dad
does no so sad it's sad
okay did steph curry by winning the
title and winning the mvp
now move into the top ten all time i i
felt that he was we had this remember
two weeks ago i know
you talked about someone coming out and
yes
i i felt he was knocking on the door he
has certainly he has certainly kicked
down the door
okay i'll give you my top ten all right
go ahead again it's not fair because
it's different eras it's different rules
but this is just my top ten
my personal feeling and this is by no
means in any order i'm just throwing out
names magic
michael
steph
bill russell
lebron
kareem
kobe
tim duncan
shaq
and larry legend
those would be my tens that ten one two
three four five six seven eight nine
that that's my top ten so no oscar no
cherry
on the fringe hakeem oscar
i thought about giannis but he needs two
more championships
but to be honest certainly if he wins
two more championships someone's gonna
have to come off this list you don't
have wilton there
don't have wilt
um wilt has
two championships shaq to me as dominant
as both players were
i would go with shaq over will okay
so akeem is on the outside oscar's on
the outside jerry west is on the outside
yes jerry west only that one
championship
uh larry legend three and what three
finals in the uh two two finals finals
but three-time league mvp yeah
tim duncan that's easy colby i think is
easy kareem i think is easy lebron i
think is easy
bill russell i think is easy
stefan i think is easy
obviously jordan and magic
that's
to me that's an easy tin
you know we had the lakers coach darvin
ham on yesterday and i said all right
game on the line
i'll give you ray allen who you played
with i'll give you steph curry i'll give
you a kobe
and i'll give you larry
bird you know who he picked
game on the line
for a shot or you need that game to shut
up win everything a shot 40 minutes
a three-pointer to win the game a
three-pointer to win and it's ray steph
larry legend and who was the fourth kobe
he probably darvin ham probably went
with
stephen curry
kobe bryant larry lynch
yes yes
and i apologize that i didn't include
you in that group
former teammate of mine i'm surprised
darvin hamm didn't i know i know he
should have said i got a write-in ballot
here i'm going to put reggie miller in
there i i still steph didn't need the
finals mvp he did it felt like the media
needed him to have that i don't i don't
think steph went boy my
my career has got this large void in
there because i would have given it to
him in 2015 instead of iguodala
he should have won and what's funny is
i don't know which one of my net
danettes brought up
you know
steph kind of gets looked upon or
frowned upon because kd joined the team
i i almost think it's kind of the other
way around now right yeah because until
kd wins a championship
people will look at him like well you
had to join a 72 win team
to get two championships and possibly
would have been three if he never would
have gotten hurt correct i think it's a
compliment to steph that kd won
absolutely to join that that team not
only a compliment to
stefan but the warriors organization to
be able to lure the best player at the
time
away from one of its competitors
remember this is the same oklahoma city
team that had those warriors 72 win team
down what 3-1
and lost yeah
and then lured him away to come play
with us
to win two more
so let's give him a credit to bob myers
and upper management along with the
players obviously draymond and clay
and stefan they had to be willing to you
know bring on the best player like a
kevin durant but let's give them a lot
of credit for selling hey
we have something special building here
and you can be a part of that
best six foot four and under player of
all time i'm guessing you're gonna say
steph because he's in the top ten and
everybody else is at least six six i i
think first of all it's a short list
right so uh i guess you would no no pun
intended no pun intended there
all right
i guess you would put isaiah in there
you would put allen iverson in there
obviously stefan
uh jason kidd gary payne i believe they
were six four below correct yeah
stocked in so this is our list oscar
he was 6'5
oscar 6'5 okay jerry west was six two
six three
so steph is one steph is the best
uh you know dwyane wade six four
is dwayne where are you only six four
i thought he was taller but i think he's
listed at six four i think he's six five
oh so he doesn't make it why do you guys
lie about your your height
don't we all
because everyone wants to
to you know be taller no bill walton who
has to be at least 7-2
was listed at 6 11. he's 7-2 and he said
he didn't he thought seven-footers were
viewed as freaks
and so bill would say he's 6 11. and i'd
see him next to robert parish who's 7-1
and he'd be taller than him by a couple
inches
think about the source coming from a
grateful dead fanatic that's his
thinking that's his logic
love you bill but come on he was 7-2
what advice we're talking to reggie
miller what advice would you give jason
tatum this off-season
i would say
understand and relish in the
disappointment of that series versus
golden state it's painful
i've been there
but at 24 23 24 the future is bright
and
to me his star is only going to ascend
and rise
and if he can take that pain
of how that felt
and use it to his advantage i think the
celtics have something special brewing
there but his game though reg that's
what concerns me
it's sloppy
but at 23 24 there's a lot of
we said the same thing about giannis too
yeah but giannis has gotten better every
single year and he was he was a project
tatum was a skilled guy who came out of
duke and i think he can only get better
but he doesn't take care of he doesn't
make good decisions with the ball i
would love to see him when the shot is
not you know connecting from three-point
range
do what all the great players eventually
did they went down on the block
right put it down and got into the pain
and got fouled we got to defeat the line
yeah
look that's a
that's something that can be learned
right and that's through film work and
that's through experience
i'm not worried about jason tatum i
look i know it's disappointing because
we were ready to anoint him and i get it
but you can't discredit what he did
throughout this postseason against some
of the all-time greats in our game and
kevin durant and giannis and jimmy
butler you can't discredit that he was a
easter conference finals mvp yeah
all right and we're taking six games and
throwing everything else out the window
what about all those other games that
matter those game sevens when they were
down three two when they when it was
facing elimination and how big he came
up let's not
let's not throw him under the bus quite
yet i think there's room for growth for
tatum okay but i look at the celtics and
i don't like mark as smart as my point
guard
uh you know i like him in the lineup i
like what he does
but
handicap this celtic team as they move
forward what do they need to add
very fair well number one they added a
healthy robert williams back yeah
i think he is huge
for what hime udoka and the celtics want
to do going forward what he does
defensively and how he
patrols the paint and covers up
everyone's mistakes if he's healthy
maybe this is a different series but we
could talk about that later
and you're right they've got to find a
rondo
former celtic type point guard a real
point guard that can direct and
understand and take the temperature of
what's going on
and assess
what needs to be done out there on the
floor i love marker smart and i love
what he brings to any team especially
the celtics i mean he's defensive player
of the year you've got to have guys like
him and grant williams and robert
williams on your team to win
championships guys that you don't have
to run a single play for but they can be
impactful
at both ends of the floor and that's
what marcus smarts bring is he my
starting point guard no but they need a
real tight point guard the window for
the warriors to win another championship
or two
or three is what
well they've got a lot of decisions to
make this season i think kavon looney is
up i think uh
jordan poole his
deal his rookie deal is up so
are they going to resign him and open up
the bank to him andrew wiggins is up
you've got jonathan caminga who didn't
might have played 10 minutes this whole
final series he's on deck but can he do
what
you know
andrew wiggins did
so they've got some decisions to make
and that's going to be i mean bob myers
you're working off a championship now
but you've got some key pieces and some
hard hard decisions with three guys that
are taking a bulk of the salary in clay
steph and draymond
i mean
god bless them if they want to win
another championship do they bring
everyone back which i don't think
they're going to be able to do
kavon looney has certainly earned
a big payday will it be with the
warriors
that remains to be seen
we had chris maddox on last hour and
manic said i said what are some
storylines to keep an eye on over the
summer he said if portland strikes out
in free agency
then
look at what's going to happen
uh with dame time also bradley beal does
bradley beal want to stay in washington
uh deandre ayton does he stay in phoenix
rudy gobert
um you know it feels like there's
there's a couple of
possible moving
parts here that could change
you know the complexion of a a roster
here coming up over the summer
sir i'm just gonna the names you
mentioned
how could this change
some of these playoff teams that we just
saw what would you think if bradley bill
teamed up with jimmy butler in miami
what would you think of the brooklyn
nets
if rudy gobert joined that team
i mean
think about it
what if damien lillard
finds a way to get to boston
that that changes these teams and chris
mattis is right
if some of these big name guys
and if their organization decides look
we we need a fresh look it's time to
move on yeah
i mean i i hate bradley bill and jimmy
butler that would be that would be fun
to watch
but it feels i always feel like damien
lillard is going to end up with a knicks
and i
and i hate thinking about that
i think he'll be in the same predicament
he was in portland
i know
but but i keep thinking oh god he's just
going to get more publicity but he's not
going to get
you know results here
he's going to be doing his modelo beer
commercial but he'll be playing for the
next he'll be drinking while he's
playing because he's playing for the
knicks here red
uh
yeah
look the knicks need a point guard bat
and they need a name point guard and
damien lillard certainly is at the top
of the list right
i think he would be he might even be
worse off truthfully if he joined the
knicks versus staying with portland yeah
because i don't know what ayton does it
feels like phoenix doesn't want to offer
in the max and that he'll end up
someplace else and and he's a nice
player rudy gobert if you know you gave
the nets a rim protector i mean that's
pretty formidable if boston would add a
player like that miami would add bradley
beal i don't know bradley beal i think
said he wanted to be sort of a dirk
nowitzki and he's going to stay with
the washington
wizards but i love that nothing wrong
with that i'd love that hopefully they
can build around them i'm just saying if
there is rumblings of him
if management is like look we we need to
turn the page and you always get april
and may off if you play for the wizards
so that's good oh
come on wait too soon
i'm better than that i am i'm better
than that
i'm doing better than that um
thanks again always great to have you uh
your contributions your uh
opinions your love your enthusiasm so uh
have a great summer uh any big plans for
the fam
it's bike season now for us so i got a
lot of races coming up and i appreciate
always coming on here come
you know nba playoff time we have fun
we're very opinionated you know how much
i love my danettes yeah and next season
what's funny is we're gonna we're gonna
win our emmy i i really do believe that
next season is our season and from then
on we're gonna be like a dynasty we're
gonna be like the warriors we're gonna
win four emmys in a row in a row
theodore
yeah yeah i think we might be like you
know dirk nowitzki it might be just a
one-and-done morning but i'll take that
i'll take it all right because i'm
winning for you
and the pacers
like i'm winning for everybody i mean
that's a lot to ask for us to make up
for all the disappointment you provided
the pacer fans
great great
you are the best shooting bicyc
bicyclist in the world
okay
see that's that's my claim to fame now
there's nobody unless steph curry starts
riding a bike
well clay does ride a bike
you're a better shooter than clay aren't
you ah stop it okay not my bad i'm not
big
but you are
but you are
but
i mean yeah okay yeah you are
thank you congratulations thank you
thank you for being here
four draymond four andre four
congratulations dub
thank you reg we'll take a break we're
back after this close-up shop on this
friday after this